البحث عن جي يقال انه وفط صين حتى الان
اين وصلت
لا
الوفد الموجود هنا في الموقع ليس وفدا
صينية
نعم نعم اتحدث عن الموقع الموجود فيه الان
انا هناك عدد من
الطرق الطاقم اجنبي اوروبي حتى الان لم
نتاكد من جنسيه الطاقم لكن بالعموم
كما نتابع معكم على ما يبدو الان تم اخراج
ضحيه او جثه اخرى من تحت الانقاض هذا ما
يبدو الينا ما يبدو لنا الان في هذه
الصوره سنحاول ايضا الحديث عن هذا الموضوع
زيدان اعلم ربما
الاخيره ولكن ماذا تقول او ماذا يقول
عمالنا لانقاذ خاصه بعد مرور كمان واربعين
ساعه هل من الممكن ان تؤدي جهودهم الى
انقاذ مزيد من الارواح او فقط انتشال هذه
الجثث
نعم يعني ما تزال هناك يعني جهود على
الانقاذ مستمر الان اخرجوا الجثه سينقلون
الى خارج الموقع طبعا
سياره الاسعاف تحاول او هناك اسعاف قريبه
الان يتم نقل الضحيه كما نشاهدها لا ادري
اذا كانت الكاميرا تستطيع ان ترصد هذا
المشهد تم فتح تم فتح الثغره في هذا
المكان كان هناك يوم امس عندما كنا في هذا
الموقع كان هناك امل كان هناك ناجون داخل
هذا او تحت هذا الركام استطاعوا الحديث
استطاعت فرق الانقاذ الحديث مع
بعض الناجين ومن ثم حاولوا الوصول لكن على
ما يبدو ان الجهود ما تزال مستمره لا نعلم
حتى الان اذا كان حتى الان في هذا الموقع
هناك احياء جهود الانقاذ ما تزال مستمره
الخبراء هناك خبراء متخصصون بهذا الموضوع
في اداره الكوارث والتعامل موضوعهم من
يقودون هذه العمليه طبعا عشرات المتطوعين
وايضا من فرق الانقاذ المتخصصه لكن هناك
فريق كان فريق تركي يشرف على هذا الموضوع
ووصل صباح هذا اليوم اعيد تاكيدات
المعلومه فريق اجنبي